about why the shadow transport minister
thinks sam terry is with us now hello to
mr terry um
how do you feel about defying um the
leader why are you doing it
i'm not defying anybody i'm the shadow
secretary of state for transport i'm
here supporting 40 000 low paid
transport workers who've decided to go
on strike look this is something that's
important that people realize these
workers are not massively well paid
they're safety critical workers they're
people that work in ticket offices these
are people often paid 25 000 pounds or
less labor will always stand on the side
of workers who are making very difficult
decisions
last few weeks in my constituency our
food bank ran out of food because people
couldn't afford to donate to the food
bank we've got doctors talking about
going on strike nurses we've got
communication workers in the postal
service we've got lecturers all across
the country industrial disputes are
breaking out for a very simple reason
this government doesn't care about
ordinary working people in britain
instead they've had 10 years of
austerity and not even able to come
forward with serious offers in terms of
at least even matching the level of
inflation for people's pay rises across
the public and private sectors
yeah earlier this week he said do not go
on to picket lines and you did
if kirsten was in number 10 i wouldn't
be standing here today because it
wouldn't be an industrial dispute if i
was running the department for transport
we would have set the parameters for the
14 train operating companies for network
rail to make sure and for that matter
tfl to make sure that there was enough
money coming forward and enough serious
discussions taking place with the tssa
rmt and on saturday the azdef unions to
make sure that we didn't need to be an
industrial dispute this is very simple
you can't turn around to workers that
kept britain running during the pandemic
and say you know what you're going to
have to suck on it we're going to give
you less than a rate of inflation so
therefore you need to accept a below
inflation pay cut that's clearly not
acceptable there's not a single labour
mp thinks that's acceptable and i
believe that kyocera doesn't think
that's acceptable the key thing today is
to say under the labour government these
industrial disputes would not be
happening it's the government the tory
government that's agitating for these
things to happen we've got two tory
leadership contestants in a bidding war
to dismantle 200 years of workplace
rights that we've built up in this
country that's what you get in tory
britain you get inflation out of control
10 years of austerity below inflation
pay offers and dismantling our hard-won
freedoms and riots that would never
happen under a labour government and i
tell you what the sooner we have a
general election and the sooner kia
stammer and i'll be working every single
day to get him into number 10 is in
charge of this country british workers
will be far far better off you might not
because you might get sacked
this isn't about me and what happens to
me this is about the 40 000 people that
decided to lose a day's pay people who
have paid not very much money at all
that's the focus of today it's about
saying there's a red line that needs to
be drawn in the sand because the way the
government are treating workers across
britain is absolutely disgraceful you
know they rush through legislation just
a few weeks before the end of parliament
to be able to bring in strike breakers
look at their disgraceful actions over
piano look at the disgraceful way they
fail to support workers at british
airways people in britain have had
enough k and it's about time people
started standing shoulder to shoulder
with workers because they are the people
that will vote in the next labour
government
um the chairperson for the labour party
has just been on the telly and she says
it's up to the whips to decide what
happens to you next do you think you
might lose your job for insubordination
my focus today as it always is is making
sure that labour's message of what we
are going to do just answer my question
because i have like it i'll let you do
that for a good five or six minutes now
my question is are you prepared to get
sacked for insubordination
i've not been into normal to anyone i
support kia osama i think he's by far
the best person to be prime minister of
this country i believe he will be the
prime minister of this country my job
today is to support transport workers as
a shadow transport minister to support
the travelling public look kay we've
just had the hottest days on record in
british history the climate crisis is
totally out of control and yet we're
here on a dispute when actually our
public transport networks should be
pumped full of money so that they are
able to work and to function we can get
people onto trains off of planes out of
their cars and onto trains this isn't
just about this dispute here today this
is about the future of our country and
the future of our planet and i tell you
what under a labour government this
dispute wouldn't be happening kierstarma
would be very clear that we would have
fair pay officers for every worker with
a public or private sector across this
country and i believe that is why we
will win the next general election
okay um how much do you think the rail
workers should get paid as a percentage
increase
i think it depends depending on the
grade depends on the different job i'm
not in those negotiations but i tell you
what is not acceptable offering people
below inflation pay rises that is
clearly not acceptable because that's
saying to people you need to have a pay
cut instead of a pay rise that's clearly
not something that's going to help this
dispute get ended anytime soon okay so
you're suggesting above inflation pay
rises for rail workers i'm guessing for
all workers
i'm suggesting that every worker
deserves a pay rise that is in line with
inflation and at the moment the rmt and
tsa have been offered four percent this
year when inflation is running at 11 and
then at 2 on the following two years
that is a real terms pay cut no worker
should be offered a pay cut as a way
forward whilst having a sort of gun put
to their head in terms of losing their
jobs remember many ticket office staff
are facing actually losing their careers
entirely because they're being told that
ticket offices are not going to be part
of the future in the railways we'll tell
that to disabled or blind passengers
trying to get onto trains or trying to
buy a ticket just doesn't work for them
instead of attacking our public
transport network the government should
be supporting it
okay um so you're suggesting all public
sector workers should get at least 11
what's that going to do to inflation
i didn't say that okay at all
that's exactly what you said you said
they should get at least this nation and
then you said serious negotiations
around the table exactly what you said
serious negotiations around the table
there needs to be serious negotiations
across every dispute that's going on in
this country because the reality is it
is not acceptable for people to be in a
situation where even the food banks are
running out of food how do you explain
to a worker having to put over 100 pound
into a tank of fuel or paying 1500
pounds a month just to sort of heat and
have electricity in a two-bedroom house
you know this is totally out of control
the government needs to get a grip and
instead of waging war on workers what
they need to do is actually support
ordinary workers in britain so public
you did say 11 for uh public sector
workers that's exactly what you said uh
are you going back on that now
i'm saying very clearly that inflation
is out of control but putting forward
pay rises that are serious that actually
because you have to remember right a lot
of public sector and private sector
workers have not had pay rises for more
than a decade so actually even if you
were to match inflation now you still
wouldn't be catching up with where
workers were
if they'd had you know rises in line of
inflation over the last decade at what
point k do you think it's fair for
workers to stand up and say enough is
enough we can't feed our families we
can't pay our bills we can't put fuel in
the car to get to work they can't even
afford to probably buy the train tickets
to get to work that is not acceptable
and people have had enough